Taiwán ha informado hoy del primer drone
que habría enviado a China a su zona de
identificación de defensa aérea se trata
de un nuevo dron de reconocimiento que
también tiene capacidad militar se llama
tb1 y la prensa china lo ha bautizado
como escorpión de dos colas puede
alcanzar grandes altitudes y tiene una
autonomía de vuelo de Ni más ni menos
que 6000 km cuando recordemos que la
distancia media en el estrecho de
formosa es de 180 km es por eso que los
expertos Creen que a China le sería de
extrema utilidad en caso de guerra si lo
enviará a la costa Oriental es decir a
la opuesta al estrecho de formosa El
dron ha sido registrado en el informe
diario que elabora taipei con las
incursiones de aviones chinos en su zona
de identificación de defensa aérea esa
zona no la reconoce China y de todas
formas queda muy lejos de suelo taiwanés
en las últimas 24 horas han sido 19
aviones muchos de los cuales habrían
cruzado la línea media Es decir la
frontera oficiosa en el estrecho la
incursión del dron Sigue a las maniobras
militares que este mes ordenó Beijing
tras la visita a Estados Unidos de la
presidenta Child donde se reunió con el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes Kevin mccarthy fueron
tres días fragorosos en los que Beijing
ensayó el bloqueo aéreo y marítimo de la
isla y el ataque quirúrgico a sus
objetivos más sensibles